el tan esperado día finalmente llegó
para inglaterra desde londres hasta
liverpool después de 17 meses de pistas
de baile vacías las discotecas de
inglaterra vuelven a abrir sin
restricciones
a partir de este lunes se levantan casi
todas las restricciones impuestas como
consecuencia de la pandemia en
inglaterra fin de la obligación de
llevar mascarilla fin del
distanciamiento social y vuelve el aforo
habitual a bares y restaurantes el
primer ministro mantiene sin embargo las
advertencias crisis
y este es el momento adecuado pero
tenemos que ser cautelosos tenemos que
estar conscientes de que el virus sigue
allí y de que el número de casos está en
aumento conocemos lo extremadamente
contagiosa que puede ser la variante de
alta pero tenemos al gran consuelo la
satisfacción de saber que el programa de
vacunación ha debilitado fuertemente el
vínculo entre la enfermedad la
hospitalización y la moral en the
builders neidhart el propio boris
johnson se vio obligado a autorizarse
hasta el 26 de julio tras haber estado
en contacto con su secretario de salud
ssa sitiavw y quien dio positivo por
coronavirus para los expertos del
levantamiento de restricciones es
prematuro animando bucks and life aunque
la vacunación ha debilitado
significativamente el vínculo entre las
infecciones las hospitalizaciones
todavía estamos en una posición muy
difícil aquí en inglaterra y no creo que
sea el momento adecuado para levantar
todas las restricciones o stations el
gobierno se apoya en un rápido plan de
vacunación con el que casi el 70% de la
población de gran bretaña ya ha sido
totalmente vacunado
sin embargo la apuesta por la
recuperación económica vendrá acompañada
por un inevitable aumento de contagios
debido a la presencia de la variante
delta y por la posibilidad de la
aparición de nuevas mutaciones del virus